one of the most powerful features of
google cloud compute engine is managed
instance groups
managed instance groups let you
automatically scale your application out
to handle those peak loads and
automatically heal in case one of your
instances go down today i'm going to do
a quick dive into manage instance groups
and show you how easy it is to set one
up for your application
on google cloud an instance group is
simply a group of virtual machines that
can be managed as a single entity
a managed instance group is an instance
group of identical vms created based on
an identical instance template
a managed instance group introduces a
whole bunch of functionality like auto
scaling for increasing the size of your
group depending on the load auto healing
for automatically replacing unhealthy
instances and multi-zone deployments for
higher availability
before i get into any of that let's
review the four google cloud resources
that are associated with creating a
managed instance group first is the
instance group manager
this represents the managed instance
group itself
the configuration of a manage instance
group manager will include whether the
instance group will be zonal or regional
and if regional which zones to
distribute the instances across it'll
also include the number of instances in
the group and specify the second
resource that we need the instance
template the instance template is
essentially the cookie cutter that the
manage instance group manager will use
to provision vms in the group the
instance template will specify much of
the same configuration that you might
include in a standalone instance like
machine size disks networking settings
and more
you'll only need one template but you do
have the option of specifying multiple
ones so you can do things like roll out
canary builds of your applications to
only a subset of your instance group
next we have a health check
a health check is only required if you
want to enable auto healing on your
instance group
that's when instances are automatically
replaced when they repeatedly failed a
health check
these health checks are the same ones a
load balancer would use to direct
traffic to healthy instances
for managed instance groups it's used to
decide whether the instance needs to be
reprovisioned
when creating a health check you can
choose from five different protocols and
you can specify how rigorous you want
the health check to be by adjusting the
check interval and thresholds if you
plan on using auto scaling the last
thing you'll need to have is an auto
scaling policy the auto scaling policy
has all the configuration that
determines under what circumstances new
instances will be added to and removed
from the group
it isn't required for a managed instance
group and it can be enabled and disabled
after being added let's take a quick
look at how we can set up all of these
resources and have a managed instance
group up and running in no time in this
demonstration i'll be working from a new
project with no existing resources
and i'll have only the compute admin im
role assigned in the google cloud
console you'll find an instance group
under compute engine in the navigation
menu
you can create everything you need for
your manage instance group in one shot
by clicking create instance group
after giving it a snazzy name the first
thing you'll want to do is choose from
these three choices stateless managed
instance group stateful management group
or unmanaged instance group
stateful and stateless managed instance
groups are similar except stateful will
let you preserve disks
let's choose a stateless managed
instance group the next big choice you
have to make is a location
a zonal managed instance group will
provision vms in one single zone and is
fine for most use cases but remember
that a regional managed instance group
will improve your availability by
spreading your instances across several
zones
when you choose multiple zones it'll let
you specify which zones in that region
you want to distribute your instances
across
choose at least three to maximize
availability next let's specify an
instance template
if the project doesn't have one we can
create it right here
for this example i'll just create a
simple template that will create an e2
medium with a debian boot disk
next
let's add an auto scaling policy in this
section here
for this demonstration i'll leave it
with the default values i'll dive deeper
into all these settings like cooldown
period and scaling controls in a later
video
by default it's going to use cpu
utilization at 60 as a metric that it
uses to scale up but you can adjust that
percentage or replace the metric with
load balancer utilization or a
stackdriver monitoring metric
if you want you can also add additional
metrics by hitting add new metric
there's no one-size-fits-all
configuration here it's going to depend
on your application's needs but the
default values will work for most use
cases
one thing i will change is the minimum
number of instances because remember
this is a regional instance group so i
want to make sure that i have at least
one instance in each of the zones that i
specified down here at the bottom is
where we configure auto healing by
specifying a health check
i don't have one yet so i'll just create
a new one the default here is tcp
if your application needs something
different you have the options of these
other protocols in this list
i'll select http and specify the request
path for the health page of my web
application
down here under health criteria is where
we indicate how frequently the health
check should run and at what point to
consider the state of an individual
instance as unhealthy
with these default values the health
check will run against each instance
every 10 seconds
if it doesn't receive the response it's
looking for in 5 seconds it'll count
that as a failure
three consecutive failures means the
health check state will be unhealthy and
will only become healthy again after two
consecutive successes once we're done
here we're ready to create our manage
instance group with auto scaling and
auto healing
you can click create down here or
command line to see the corresponding
gcloud commands
you can see here the four resources
we're creating the instance template
the health check
the instance group itself
and finally the auto scaling policy
that's a really quick rundown but
there's plenty more you can do to get
the most out of your managed instance
groups
for example enabling predictive auto
scaling will feed your instance group's
historical trends and current load into
a machine learning model so that the
auto scaler can anticipate auto scale
events
this way the auto scaler will behave
more proactively and have machines ready
to roll with less time waiting for
machines to initialize for more
information on managed instance groups
and all they have to offer check out the
link to the documentation below
in the next video i'm going to discuss
in more detail how you can make the most
out of your managed instance groups by
making sure you have an effective auto
scaling policy see you then